il ya deux mondes qui se rencontre on a
vraiment le monde du pc portable de la
bureautique familiale et on a de l'autre
côté le monde du gamer qui commence un
petit peu arriver doucement que cette
machine c'est pour moi une machine qui
est vraiment aujourd'hui je vous parlais
ordinateur gaming et vous parlez d'un
ordinateur de dell vous le savez je t'ai
de plus en plus d'ordinateurs
j'aime bien ça je trouve ça cool et j'ai
testé ya pas très longtemps ordinateurs
de dell fin deux ordinateurs c'est les
xps 15 pouces là on est dans tout autre
chose on est dans le dell kace pouces
c'est l'ordinateur gaming de la marque
des l'cie vous le savez dès là une
marque timing dévié s'appelle alienware
qui est vraiment la marque pour les
gamers mais malgré tout donc quand même
fabriquer un produit
dell d'ennemis destiné aux casual gamers
qu'un joueur guimond l'idée c'est
vraiment de séduire les personnes qui
vont jouer occasionnellement qui aime
bien jouer mais qui veut pas forcément
acheter un pc gaming dédié et puis
vraiment connoté gaming alors on va
faire un tour de ce pc vous allez voir
il a vraiment des points très très très
positif il ya aussi quelques fois un peu
négatif on peut pas tout avoir
parce que c'est une bécane qui est très
bien placée en termes de tarifs en
termes de design c'est vraiment un
mélange entre un ordinateur classique
via l'ordinateur gaming qui nous permet
vraiment de repérer que celle des cannes
de gaming déjà vous avez un logo rouge
ici d'elle ça pour le coup ça change
vous avez ici les grandes grilles de
ventilation d'un petit peu dans les
codes du gaming également à l'avant mais
malgré tout on pourrait le prendre pour
un pc un petit peu plus ce temps là si
vous le regardez comme ça et qu'il est
posé sur un bureau n'a pas forcément
arriver se dire tiens ça c'est une
bécane de gaming
ensuite lorsque vous venez l'ouvrir on a
retrouvé un petit peu les codes du
gaming notamment ici là au niveau du
trackpad vous avez petite bordure rouge
mais mise à part ça vous le regardez
comme ça posé sur un bureau vous dit pas
tout de suite ça c'est un ordinateur
gaming vous avez ici une webcam en hd
720p
vous trouvez un clavier qui fonctionne
bien mais ce n'est pas non plus
complètement dingue
ici un pavé numérique forcément
ordinateur guinea oblige et votre
trackpad qui est située la la poussant
du trackpad peut vraiment être à mon
avis là dessus un point négatif parce
que lit vraiment trop décalé sur la
gauche par rapport à l'ensemble du
clavier
vraiment aligné avec cette partie utile
là par rapport au pavé numérique ce qui
fait que même tout en train d'appuyer
sur la partie gauche pas sur la partie
droite ça c'est un petit peu un point de
regrets en tout cas au niveau du clavier
je leur ai quand même centrer davantage
après en terme de connectique
franchement ça fait le boulot je pense
pas que la position soit vraiment idéal
mais malgré tout ça fonctionne vous avez
ici un lecteur de carte sd vous avez un
port usb de ce côté rj45 ici votre
alimentation
de l'autre côté vous avez du hdmi deux
ports usb type a est ici vous avez une
prise casque micro qui fonctionne très
bien
le design est pas mal et c'est vraiment
ça qui est intéressant parce qu'on se
retrouve avec un pc qui est vraiment à
mi chemin entre le pc gaming
le pc portable standard pour qu'on voit
très bien que là dessus d'elle va pas
cibler les hardcore gamers
les personnes qui veulent vraiment jouer
énormément à des jeux pour ces
personnes-là d'elle à sa marque
alienware qui sera vraiment destiné aux
hardcore gamers
là vous êtes sur une machine polyvalente
dès lors vous avez joué vous les joies
des jeux mais pas tout le temps que vous
devez faire de la bureautique du
multimédia sur l'utilisation qui peut je
dirais 50 50
cette machine là est fait pour vous on a
un écran 15,6 pouces full hd 1920 par
c'est une dalle épaisse c'est du lcd il
fonctionne pas trop mal mais c'est parce
qu'à mieux ce que je peux leur projet
c'est qu'il n'est pas assez lumineux là
j'ai poussé la luminosité à fond et si
vous comparez à côté d'autres bécane
s'est pas complètement ça en fonction
des conditions de luminosité que vous
avez dans votre pièce de lumière
ambiante et vous allez galéré un petit
peu si vous êtes comme moi dans une
pièce fermée ou l'oral qu'une fenêtre
ouverte vous près votre position très
très très facilement
si par contre dans un endroit qui est
extrêmement lumineux très grosse
luminosité intérieure ou alors carrément
extérieur plein été ça va être vraiment
limite ça va être un petit peu ça un
point de regret sur cette bécane
mais une fois de plus lorsque vous êtes
dans une pièce où la lumière est
maîtrisé ça fera parfaitement la faire
au niveau graphique c'est franchement
pas mal du tout vous avez une nvidia
geforce gtx 1060 nax qu design qui
fonctionne plutôt pas mal alors on
aurait pu aller plus loin mais une fois
de plus on est sur une bécane pour les
casual gamer on aurait pu avoir une 1070
ou carrément 1080 mais bon sur une
machine comme ça ça va très bien que ça
permet surtout à dell de vous sortir un
tarif très intéressant en termes de
performances ça fonctionne aussi très
bien vous avez une intel core i5 de
huitième génération vous voulez briller
jusqu'à un intel core i7
ça fait à faire ça fonctionne très bien
vous avez une giga de ram vous pouvez
monter jusqu'à 16 giga de ram moi j'ai
beaucoup utilisé avec un casque de
réalité virtuelle des ailes croyez-moi
ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal ça à la up
alors j'ai toujours à l'air un peu bête
quand je le prends comme ça avec les
contrôleurs vous faites de la vr
franchement c'est hyper fluide ça
fonctionne super bien j'ai fait tourner
plein de jeux dessus je suis super
content parce que en termes de puissance
pour moi que j'ai ri cinq là avec 8 giga
drame c'est parfait alors après t'être
qui aura des jeux très gourmands qui
vont être moins performant pour moi son
ordinateur pour ducobu un gamer c'est
pas forcément la décale pour le hardcore
gamer qui est vraiment une puissance de
dengue qui veut vraiment des pères
complètement ouf est hallucinante
mais pour moi pour les trois quarts des
jeux ça fonctionne extrêmement bien à et
pour le vr
c'est top et maintenant côté stockage le
mieux c'est de prendre un ssd ssd 128
giga ssd 256go aller directement sur 256
giga ça coûte forcément un peu plus cher
et vous vous y retrouverez franchement
on se retrouve avec une autonomie qui
est franchement bonne entre cinq à six
heures complètement débranché
ça c'est plutôt cool alors que vous êtes
en déplacement vous allez prendre le
train vous pouvez pas le brancher 5h
franchement ça fonctionne vous serez pas
déçus et en fonction de votre
utilisation
vous allez pouvoir monter un peu plus
alors guère plus 5h30 6 heures mais
franchement c'est déjà bien et votre
système d'exploitation on a un windows
dix familles nickel et vous pouvez
également la voir avec linux si ça vous
intéresse
la partie audio est ok mais pas
complètement folle vous avez des hauts
parleurs qui sont situées juste la
justice'' devant caché là la leçon et
pousse à fond voilà il ya du son c'est
pas extrêmement fort been la qualité
samson qui est un petit peu médium
pourrait s'attendre à voir un truc un
peu plus performant là dessus une fois
de plus dell a fait des choix pour avoir
de la puissance
éval économies sur certains postes si
vous voulez vraiment ordinateur gaming
qui nous permet d'avoir un son est
vraiment bien je vous conseille de
monter en gamme d'aller sur les
alienware fois positif également c'est
pas une bécane qui va chauffer lorsque
vous le mettez des grandes sessions de
jeu
il va pas se mettre à chauffer ça c'est
plutôt cool alors par contre les
ventilateurs lorsqu'il parle vous les
entendez ça me paraît assez normal on
sentait vraiment une diffusion de la
chaleur qui complètement maîtrisé sur
cette machine là ça c'est aussi un point
qui est qui est plutôt cool il n'est pas
particulièrement bruyants non plus on
entend les ventilateurs c'est normal il
faut réguler la température à
l'intérieur mais c'est hallucinant au
final pour moi cette machine c'est un
excellent rapport qualité prix
parce que comme je vous le disais c'est
pas une machine qui va destiné aux
personnes qui jouent énormément et qui
ont besoin de deux besoin vraiment très
très spécifiques et des choses pour
avoir de la puissance et pour avoir une
vraie machine connoté gaming mais pour
des personnes qui aiment jouer de temps
en temps qui veulent de la puissance qui
veulent une machine qui est quand même
un peu race et franchement je trouve que
le g5 dell fait vraiment bien le faire
on est sur un alliage magnésium
plastique qui franchement donne une
vraie belle sensation de robustesse la
connectique je trouve assez complète
après la disposition on peut toujours en
parler c'est pas forcément complètement
optimale néanmoins vous avez tout ce
qu'il faut dessus maintenant ce qui me
dérange là dessus c'est la luminosité
qui est pas optimal
le son qui est pas ou florent le général
on va jouer avec un casque dont bon ça
éventuellement on peut s'en passer
la position du trackpad est pas terrible
le fait qu'elle soit vraiment décalé sur
la gauche
c'est probablement une question
d'habitude parce que cette machine j'ai
utilisé pendant un certain temps mais
c'est pas mon ordinateur principal
peut-être qu'à force on trouve
naturellement sa position il faut
s'habituer mais c'est vrai que tout de
suite lorsqu'on la prend en main on a
toujours tendance à faire du clic gauche
y'a pas de prêts très bien se
positionner bon c'est pas extrêmement
par contre point très positif vous avez
de la puissance de la performance une
machine polyvalente qui franchement très
bien et qui surtout en terme de tarif
est extrêmement bien placé on commence à
879 euros pour la config de base avec un
i5 et après ça va monter ça va dépendre
effectivement de ce que vous voulez on
va monter à 300 euros voir un petit peu
plus
moi je trouve que l'ep sud elle a
vraiment un très bon compromis très bon
compromis il ya deux mondes qui se
rencontre on a vraiment le monde du pc
portable de la bureautique familiale et
on a d'autres côté le monde du gamer qui
commence un petit peu arriver doucement
que cette machine c'est pour moi une
machine qui est vraiment idéal pour
faire un premier pas dans le monde du
gaming forcément vouloir sauter le pas
directement excellent rapport qualité
prix pas très cher bien positionné
robuste je vous le conseille je trouve
vraiment bien et puis je vous le dis moi
ce que je vous conseille avec je sais
pas alors si vous aimez ou pas mais si
vous aimez de là vers vous prenez un
casque de réalité virtuelle de dell avec
vous prenez les contrôleurs pour moi la
tentation est complètement ouf j'adore
la vr6 c'est pas le but de cette vidéo
aujourd'hui mais en parle un petit peu
j'adore la vr je trouve que ce casque de
dell fonctionne plutôt pas mal je me
souviens plus des specs je crois qu'on
en 1440 par 1440 sur chaque oeil et vous
le faites marcher avec une machine comme
ça vous serez pas déçus pour faire
également un premier pas d'un nom de
gaming en réalité virtuelle c'est plutôt
cool et c'est assez bluffant
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous êtes des
moeurs est ce que cette machine bah vous
la connaissez ce qu'elle vous tentait ce
qu'elle peut vous tenter est ce que vous
l'avez est-ce que vous avez des
alienware
est-ce que vous avez des produits de dl
et qu'est ce que vous pensez tout savoir
vous marquez tout son commentaire
quotidien a parlé de bécanes
d'ordinateur vous invite à des consulter
ma playlist précis trouvait à la bécane
qui vous correspond et puis on reste
connectés aux andras soyez sages et à
très bientôt
ciao